it is the time of year for winter
activities from skiing and snowboarding
to sledding but a new national poll
suggests parents may not always consider
the risks only 75 percent say their
child wears a helmet skiing or
snowboarding for sledding only a third
of parents say their child wears a
helmet always or sometimes
wearing a helmet when sledding really
isn't the norm yet even though there are
some experts that recommend helmets
and here's why you might want to make it
your norm meet bailey knight at age nine
in a sledding accident she suffered a
crushed nose a skull fracture tears to
the lining of her brain she had five
surgeries in six years and to this day
11 years later she still suffers with
migraines and ptsd
i think it is good to
hear
other people talk about it because you
really you just don't think that it will
ever happen to you
researchers remind us that very young
children need to be supervised by an
adult at all times during winter sports
activities